[Musica]
probabilmente il punto di partenza
migliore che possiamo utilizzare è una
specie di
inversione contro intuitiva Perché
solitamente noi siamo soliti pensare che
noi esseri umani creiamo le storie e
ingenuamente forse quello che possiamo
credere ma a un livello più profondo
sono le storie che creano quello che
siamo come se noi stessi nella nostra
struttura cognitiva nel nostro modo di
fare di pensare di amare di stare al
mondo dipendessimo per molti versi per
molti versi dalle storie che ci portiamo
dentro consapevoli o meno che ne siamo
questo probabilmente accade Perché la
nostra psiche funziona in una maniera
che si accorda direttamente al ritmo
delle narrazione Non esageriamo dicendo
che il nostro modo di pensare è sempre a
forma di storytelling la nostra psiche è
davvero mitomorfa nel senso che noi la
nostra coscienza fino anche la nostra
individualità soggettiva la fondiamo in
maniera più o meno consapevole
uno più miti che definiscono quello che
siamo non ce ne accorgiamo ma il modo
che abbiamo di stare al mondo le nostre
paure più profonde I nostri entusiasmi
più alti Le nostre più pure aspirazioni
dipendono per molti versi dal mito o dai
miti che custodiamo dentro di noi Dunque
potremmo dire che l'identità soggettiva
di un singolo individuo dipende dalla
storia che lo fonda dalla storia
fondamentale che ci rende unicamente
quello che siamo
e in maniera ulteriore Possiamo anche
dire che una comunità si crea laddove
diversi individui si ritrovano attorno
al medesimo mito fondante per dirlo in
maniera ancora più chiara possiamo
chiamare comunità un gruppo di individui
distinti che però vedono il mondo
attraverso la medesima l'ente narrativa
Ma se questo è vero se una comunità
profondamente si crea perché c'è una
storia che connette le singole
soggettività altrimenti disgregate in
particelle individuali Questo significa
che il ruolo delle narrazioni è qualcosa
di profondissimo e fondamentale sia
nell'evoluzione di ogni singolo
individuo sia nell'evoluzione dei gruppi
umani probabilmente questi il motivo per
il quale in tutte le tradizioni e nella
fattispecie anche in quella occidentale
il ruolo del narratore è sempre stato
così centrale e le Storie così
determinanti dalla Grecia arcaica degli
aedi sino alla contemporaneità di
Hollywood Netflix le storie forgiano le
coscienze così facendo creano una
comunità anticamente questo ruolo dello
storyteller era definito dai Greci a Edo
parola bellissima che deriva da un verbo
Che significa cantare e raccontare il
termine ancora più preciso sarebbe
rapsodo Che significa colui o colei che
riesce a cucire delle storie insieme
connettendo individualità distinte Ma
che lo si chiami a Edo Trovatore Cantore
cantastorie storyteller o narratore
stiamo sempre parlando della medesima
figura che possiede una specie di forza
magica che gli antichi Greci correlavano
con una specie di seconda vista Non a
caso lo si chiama Omero la Edo per
antonomasia Ma è un nome parlante e
simbolico significa colui che non vede
ma come a dire che ha una specie di
seconda vista di vista ulteriore che gli
permette di vedere qualcos'altro che
cosa attraverso una l'unica facoltà
cognitiva chiamata immaginazione
all'interno di quella che è la storia
condivisa quella per la quale tutti noi
andiamo in giro facciamo le nostre cose
quotidianamente la Edo lo storyteller il
narratore è colui o colei che vede
Immagina crea e condividere una storia
alternativa e questa facoltà che i greci
chiamavano eicasia che i latini
avrebbero chiamato Fantasy e che noi
possiamo chiamare creatività
immaginazione ciò che rende tale un
narratore entrando in un teatro come
questo o in un pub noi avremmo tutti la
medesima percezione Perché la nostra
mente narra una storia alla velocità
della luce noi Comprendiamo il mondo in
questo modo quello lì dietro al bancone
e l'Oste quella è una coppia innamorata
che si tiene per mano l'uomo
addormentato sul tavolo probabilmente è
ubriaco ma il narratore la Edo ci
vedrebbe qualcos'altro magari l'Oste
sarebbe il custode di un castello e il
bancone un ponte levatoio la coppia
addormentata preda di un incantesimo
d'amore e un incantesimo invece
soporifero tiene l'ubriaco là dove si
trova ma una storia del genere la
potrebbe voglio raccontare un folle o un
bambino non a caso quelle persone che
sono solite pensare in maniera
alternativa rispetto alla storia
dominante oppure con una specifica Ars
con una specifica tekne con una
specifica tecnica il narratore la Edo
colui che infatti crea in questo senso
le storie e non importa la trama ogni
storia è una buona storia dipende
Tuttavia da come la racconti perché
anche la storia che viviamo noi nella
struttura della nostra vita nel veloce
doloroso entusiasmante breve passaggio
terrestre che ci ha concesso è molto
semplice e per certi versi
disperatamente disarmante noi nasciamo
viviamo per un po' e moriamo tutti noi
qui presenti presto tardi a un certo
punto moriremo
Scusate lo spoiler ma finisce così non
la decisione la struttura è questa solo
che se la racconti in questa maniera fa
schifo è noiosa Allora serve una
reinvenzione che non dipende dalla trama
ma dal modo con cui la storia si
racconta bene lo sapeva il più grande
tra gli aerei e tra gli storyteller Will
Shakespeare che non inventò mai nessuna
trama nelle sue 37 forse 39 opere
raccontava storie che già si sapevano E
infatti Allora come oggi si va a teatro
Non per sapere se alla fine Romeo e
Giulietta si mettono insieme lo sai che
fanno poi una minaccia ci vai per un
altro motivo perché Shakespeare come
tutti i grandi aerei ha la capacità di
farti dimenticare le nozioni per le
quali tu quella storia la conosci già E
allora al primo atto quando lui la vede
per la prima volta te ne dimentichi
quando lui pronuncia la famosa battuta
Gigi Maya Hearts love
Chill Now
for site
ma il mio cuore aveva mai amato occhi
rinnegatelo perché prima d'ora voi non
avevate mai visto la vera bellezza che
un conto è se lo dici così Un conto se
scrivi a una una su Facebook Ciao Sei
carina esci
capite che è la stessa storia ma se la
racconti in maniera diversa cambia come
quando ti innamori magari lo sai già che
non funziona che andrà a finire male ma
dentro la testa parte una storia tu
pensi lui no Lei no Lei no Lei no Lei no
Lei no Ma la storia dentro la testa
invece ha già fondato una storia d'amore
poi dici vabbè lei sì perché la storia
che ti fonda non sei tu che fondi la
storia perché la storia è ciò che ti
connette come individualità con le forze
collettive dell'inconscio comune che ci
rende uomini ed è stato sempre così È
questa la forza magica degli aedi Andra
moyenne pemusa pollutropon osmalapolla
Planck
all'inizio questi denti che parole con
questi versi con questo ritmo
risuonavano in un ambiente come questo
Certo Senza microfoni senza luci ma
all'inizio della storia occidentale c'è
una storia che ci rende quello che siamo
Andra ne è la prima parola a neer Cioè
l'uomo colui che è destinato a diventare
con il suo ritorno ciò che sente di
essere o disse
che sa di essere un re un padre e un
marito ma in mezzo al mare per la furia
di Poseidone lui non è niente è nessuno
udays come lui si presenterà parlando
con un mostro Ma così come le parole
odisseos eudes suonano molto similari
sul piano fonetico se le si pronuncia
velocemente in greco antico similmente
Ciò che distingue udisseo da nessuno
sono fragili coordinate di senso che
c'entrano con la sua storia
levagli Penelope quella donna in base
alla quale lui è se stesso e tolta la
quale se non c'è la sua presenza lui non
sa chi è levagli Telemaco quel figlio
che ha lasciato bambino e che ora
desidera rivedere uomo più di ogni altra
cosa lei va gli Itaca quella terra dove
lui è Basileus dove lui è il re Odisseo
è niente udays nessuno e vale per tutti
noi quelle fragili Eppure determinanti
coordinate di senso che fondano la
nostra storia ci rendono quello che
siamo e allora è come se la vita In un
certo qual senso fosse uno strenuo
tentativo di cercare il nostro mito il
mito che ci fonda esattamente come
Odisseo nella prima storia che gli aerei
cantarono nel nostro Occidente
viviamo davvero nel luogo in cui
desideriamo ogni giorno facciamo le cose
che vogliamo fare soprattutto siamo con
le persone con le quali vogliamo davvero
essere queste domande
disarmanti nella loro semplicità sono
irrisolvibili per un singolo soggetto a
meno che non ci si mette in ascolto
della storia che ci fonda perché quella
storia che ci rende quello che siamo
certo le coordinate cambiano per ognuno
di noi non siamo re di una isola come
Itaca e forse non abbiamo un figlio che
ci attende o una moglie che ci
corrisponde quale Penelope Eppure il
significato profondo ultimo È il
medesimo perché tutti siamo in cerca di
quelle coordinate che ci Rendano
distinti dall'essere nessuno il che
significa fondamentalmente
diventare noi stessi connettendoci con
una storia comune tale è la forza magica
delle storie la prima volta che noi lo
troviamo all'interno dell'Odissea l'eroe
sta facendo una cosa apparentemente
strana per un eroe Eppure è un eroe di
questo tipo un eroe che non combatte un
eroe che non comanda eserciti per lo
meno quando lo vediamo noi la prima
volta canto Quinto All'inizio la prima
volta che lo incontri Odisseo sta
semplicemente guardando
il mare e guardando il mare piange in
quella commozione in quelle lacrime c'è
nascosto il senso ineludibile e
inobriabile del ritorno che fonda la sua
storia in quel pianto in quella
fragilità così umana del primo degli
Eroi c'è nascosto cifrato il senso
ultimo del narrare storie anche nella
nostra cultura Se è vero che ogni storia
narra nella nostra testa un possibile
ritorno
piange perché Prigioniero di una ninfa e
leidoce lo spiega subito il motivo di
quelle lacrime e Peyote poiché la Ninfa
non gli piaceva più poiché non riusciva
più a stare lì e doveva tornare alle
coordinate di senso che lo rendevano
quello che era vale a dire il marito
padre e re e quando la dea che lo
trattiene la più bella tra tutte le idee
spiega alla Edo di nome Calypso nome che
arriva dal greco caluto cioè nascondo
cercherà per amore disperatamente di
trattenerlo fino anche contro il volere
degli Dei che le comandano È ora di
riportarlo a casa Calipso si giocherà
l'ultima carta vale a dire gli proporrà
l'immortalità
Odisseo per tutta la vita ha avuto un
superpotere e poi lui te lo posso è
intelligente e sveglio rispetto agli
altri eroi non è lui forte invincibile
come Aiace ne agile e dabile in
battaglia come Achille ha un superpotere
differente la materia grigia
l'intelligenza e questo lo rende simile
agli dei e dunque Il grande sogno per
tutta la sua vita è stato essere come
loro ora si vede davanti agli occhi
questa dea che per sette anni la
trattenuto tra le braccia e tra le gambe
proporgli quello che lui ha sempre
sognato Resta con me diventerai
immortale come noi
in quel momento l'eroe probabilmente
sente passargli dentro la testa
qualsiasi tipo di emozione Fissa la dea
con quegli occhi che leido ci descrive
Viola profondi di una bellezza
irresistibile e lei ammaliante nella sua
magnificenza lo fissa a sua volta
Sperando in cuor suo che egli rimanga
preda di quell'amore profondo e del
grande desiderio di essere immortale
E infatti Audisio per un attimo
guardando gli occhi della dea
tremano le gambe è quasi indeciso se
accettare o meno quell'invito essere
Infine un Dio trarsi fuori dalla
commedia umana dai dolori dai lutti da
quelle che sono le pene quotidiane della
nostra vita e diventare quello che ha
sempre sognato di essere un Dio fuori
dalla macina annichilente del tempo e
allora la Guarda nel volto meraviglioso
ma qualcosa Evidentemente gli scatta
nella testa
perché nell'ultimo istante poco prima di
accettare
scuote la testa e rifiuta
no torno
torna perché Penelope ha qualcosa in più
nella sua mortalità rispetto
all'immortalità di Calypso torna perché
quel figlio deve rivederlo in questa
vita non in un'altra torna perché se non
fosse a Itaca che è la sua isola lui
sarebbe comunque anche se immortale
nessuno niente udays Una briciola di
calore sparpagliata nell'ombelico del
mare e forse vale per tutti noi così
come Odisseo ritrova quelle coordinate
di senso e le cerca e le persegue fino
all'estreme conseguenze fin anche
negando la possibilità dell'immortalità
se stesso similmente Noi siamo in cerca
di quelle coordinate lì Quelle
coordinate che fondano la nostra storia
perseguendo le quali noi diventiamo noi
stessi e allora è per questo che tanto
amiamo le storie ed è per questo che le
storie Hanno tale potenza magica nella
nostra vita perché sono in grado di
creare una comunità e di rivelarci qual
quella rotta verso casa Non è importante
se quella casa necessariamente si chiami
o meno Itaca ma per un momento tu potrai
ascoltando una storia capire che sei
destinato ad essere qualcosa e ti
sentirai veramente vivo perché quelle
coordinate ti riporteranno verso la tua
essenza verso quello che sei e in bilico
sulla zattera fragile della nostra vita
anche se la nostra isola è diversa noi
ascoltando una storia Potremmo sempre
essere infiammati e dire dentro di noi
con entusiasmo quasi in coro
connettendoci con altri che diventano a
loro volta noi stessi almeno per un
istante lo potrai dire Eccola Itaca